Welcome back to the $10 million studio. I'm your internet, detective,
the guy you count on to deliver you the facts of the case here with my
$10 million studio mug. Hope you got something to drink guys.
Hope you got something handy because we're getting into it today.
Only the biggest dramas on trending Tuesdays. That's how we roll. Now.
We're a drama channel, uh, basically. So right off to get into it,
let's go to the big boy desk. Come on. Let's go. Come with me.
There we go.
Look at that high level production paid way too much money for this. What big,
big drama are we talking about today? Well, uh,
I've got a few topics for you guys. One big drama. Look at this guy.
Quitting YouTube.
This might be the last time I was saying this.
Oh yeah, you got to have the sad piano. Good job, man. Following the template.
Until next time.
Goodbye. It says thanks for the 15 years. Goodbye.
Of course it's trending as usual, 3 million views, whatever.
He's so sad. He's so you know, he he's leaving forever.
He says this might be the last time he says it.
Oh my God. You're not smiling.
You're doing it wrong.
[inaudible].
You're crying. You're not doing it right then. You're doing.
[Inaudible].
Safe. Be happy. I'll see you in 2021. Probably.
I thought this was a goodbye video. I thought, what is this?
All right, I'm gonna take the thumbnail.
Why does he have this in the video? Hey guys,
I'm going to manipulate my audience.
I got to take a thumbnail real quick and me crying. Hold on, hold on.
Got to get that light, right? Oh, I can't believe it.
Goodbye guys.
Alex was Savi Slate's month long YouTube hiatus guys.
YouTube is going on vacation. Isn't news. I mean,
I think we should be allowed to go on vacation, but you don't need to cry.
Imagine if you at your job every time before, before you left for vacation,
you go into your office. You go boss. This might be the last time I see you.
I mean, if you're not smiling, you're not doing it right. I can't even,
I can't even pretend. Imagine how stupid that would be.
This is what you tubers do. I don't know.
I'm saying anyone who fakes a goodbye from the internet deserves jail
title. Just going to say that right now. Okay. Anyways. Now next drama.
Oh, hello bet. You didn't expect to see me here at look I'm from the future.
I'm not even in uniform right now because a guys, unfortunately,
a big drama happened last night that we have to throw into the story.
Cut in the mix. So apologize if this doesn't flow perfectly,
but we got to talk about call me Carson, Twitter lost its mind. Last night,
when allegations came out that a,
this popular YouTuber with like 5 million subscribers, uh,
groomed a 17 year old. Now everybody of course lost their minds. I said, Oh,
this is terrible. It's terrible.
Until he came out that he was 19 when it happened.
So he was 19 years old talking to a 17 year old. And of course, as you know,
from the internet, uh, they're very good at having very rational,
uh, nuanced discussions about matters.
Uh, the law
[inaudible].
Yeah. So anyway, a very nuanced, balanced discussion was had.
And of course the hot takes from the internet had to come out. Uh, before,
before we had even heard anybody else's side of the story, call me Carson,
maybe a pedo allegations. Call me Carson allegations,
a neutral take drama alert. Call me Carson Cabi. Carson is not a pedo.
Call me. Carson is allegedly a pedal Callie. Carson is definitely a pedo.
Call me, Carson is a.
Hello.
I wanted to talk about this real quick because it's a big drama.
Not that I really care.
Cause I think a lot of this is overblown and kind of dumb.
There's a bit of a wrinkle because of course he sent pictures back and
forth with this minor. Uh, so let's talk about that real quick. Okay.
Number one, a 19 year old talking to a 17 year old is not big news guys.
When you talk about these things, the difference in age matters guys,
back in my day, all right. I'm to, I'm an old boomer now married up,
locked it up. But I was dating my high school sweetheart,
who eventually became my wife. And uh, yeah, she's six months older than me.
We weren't, we didn't happen to be born on the same day. So there was a time,
uh, where we could have exposed her guys. We missed our opportunity,
but where she was 18 and I was still a minor and guys, guess what?
We were still talking. Does that make her a groomer?
Does that make her a Pat out? No dude, no.
The only reason anyone's being a big deal out of it is because this guy is
internet famous. So I'm going to go ahead and say, that is off the table.
That doesn't matter. Then you have this thing of like sending, you know, picks.
Okay. Now obviously I can't relate because me and my wife, we didn't even, uh,
hold hands until we got married. But you know,
for the rest of you heathens out there, I know some of you are tempted. Okay.
Yeah. You go ahead and sin, sin the snaps. So what do we do about that?
All right, look, it's my opinion. I know this is going to sound crazy,
but if you're going to go out and say that it's not a big deal,
if a 19 year old has sex with a 17 year old,
then is it a big deal that they exchanged pictures? Um,
I think that's kind of a weird thing. Look,
I know all of you guys are lawyers and I know all of your cops and you perfectly
understand the, you know,
the balance between age of consent and Romeo and Juliet laws,
which say that the age gap matters.
And I know you guys understand where Carson lives and all that kind of stuff.
I don't care. That's not what I'm into. I'm into like, do we really care?
Do I care that a 19 year old was sharing pictures with a 17 year old and vice
versa? No, no. It happens literally every day. And probably most of you,
the guys who are like throwing stones and saying, Oh,
this guy's evil have probably done it too. You were 18.
And the girl was 17 or vice versa, which happens also all the time.
So the only thing left in this drama is that Carson is an internet service
guys. Now I would know a little thing or two about being an internet celeb.
So let me tell you, this is where my boy messed up. Okay.
And this is honestly why I don't talk to any of you. I have a role,
never talk to your fans ever.
Don't engage just if they come up to you on the street, say, Hey, Steven,
I want to know now. And it's just,
you don't do it because there is that weird power dynamic thing that everyone's
been talking about lately. I do think that that is a real thing. It exists,
even though it sounds like a book written by L Ron Hubbard. Yeah.
Power dynamics between fans.
And they're like a object of worship. They're celebrity.
I know we're just in a celebrity obsessed culture now. So, you know, that's,
that's real. And so I think that that was a mistake,
but I also think he was 19 years old. Like, I don't think that's giving,
getting its proper attention here.
The dude was 19 when I was 19,
I was dumb as a box of rocks. If I was judged on that forever,
like people are trying to say like lock them up, you know, lock them up.
Oh the cops are coming. Carsten going to be locked up. No, it's like, dude,
this guy he's young, uh, he's figuring out life. Like, should he have done it?
No, of course not.
But people are acting like he was some puppet master people are gone.
He groomed her. He was like a puppet master grow me.
You know like you're talking about some 31 year old talking to a 15 year old.
No dude, this is some awkward.
And you can read the chat log because of course they've been leaked.
This guy is some awkward cringy guy who doesn't know how to handle, you know,
relationships with women. And you can tell,
I don't think this is some massive puppeteer of fans. Uh,
I think it was a mistake. I don't think he should have done it.
I think he should in the future,
better understand his relationship with his fans.
But is this a he's he's this is a big drama.
I'm honestly disappointed with drama. Tuesdays are trending Tuesdays right now,
because feel like, is this really what everyone's freaking out about?
I don't know. I don't get it. Maybe I'm missing something.
Maybe you think that I haven't understood the complexities of the law here.
And since you guys are lawyers,
I want you to explain it to me in the comments below.
Explain to me where I'm wrong. Cause of course, uh,
the Minecraft community has been known for its nuance and
takes so, uh, yeah. I,
whatever next drama dream. The Minecraft YouTuber.
Oh yes. We're getting deep inside of this.
I found a secret never before released video. I really want to talk about guys.
Cause I really care about Minecraft speed running.
I may never have played the game. May never followed any of it,
but I deeply care. Okay. So let's check this out together.
Here we go. You don't know me. I wonder what is this? You just own me.
Cool. I don't need your assistance. Social persistence. Any problem I got,
I just put my fist in by like silence, but by this is like pieces.
I got him in play, dude.
I can't even get through two topics on trending Tuesdays before I want to go
back to what I want to talk about.
What I want to talk about, uh, is this guy,
that's what I want to talk about guys. We haven't talked about it. Locked up.
Look, I started the London real saga because I was just fascinated,
fascinated by what was going on.
But I feel like I've left a lot of you hanging and mostly it's just cause I've
just, I've wanted to just let the grift be the grift,
but lately he's done some things that I just, we have to talk about.
I'm sorry guys. No Minecraft, maybe Minecraft next trending Tuesdays guys.
Maybe we'll talk about the big, big drama in the Minecraft community.
Cause I know you guys care about that, but today we got to address this man.
What have you left me? What have I got last night? The brother got shot.
My homeboy got Jack is on crack, but just to camp work. Cause I'm show tracks,
madness, insanity, and profanity. Then some punk layman. They understand.
Give me a break. What world you live in? Death is my second guest.
My religion colors.
Oh my gosh. Okay. We've got to give credit to the guy who made that.
First of all, thank you for doing that. That was beautiful. Joe Whitaker.
He did this. Oh my gosh. So funny, my guy that is amazing. Uh,
guys, if you don't know Brian Rhodes, he's running for mayor and you know,
I haven't been talking about it cause I don't want to call attention to it.
Look really no one's covered this guy. You look up Brian Rose for mayor.
The only thing talking about Brian Rose for mayor is Brian Rose,
but he's been recently making some bold claims, real bold guys.
He says he's winning the election.
Hey,
I just wanted to check in with everyone and let you know that we are
winning. Please tell me this isn't real. And on May 7th,
we plan to move into city hall and become your next mayor for London.
At this point, there are only two people in this race,
the current mayor of London, the incumbents and us.
Is that true? Is that real?
I'm sure many of you like me are getting triggered right now.
Is it true that Brian Rose,
his digital freedom platform is becoming the official internet of London.
I don't know.
And we are soon to be actually moving into first place.
Check the odds, check the bookies out there every day,
we become more and more likely to become your next mayor of London.
So okay. You get the point guys. We don't have to play any more that clip.
He says, check the eyes, check the Buc-ee's word. Number two guys.
And we're about to, we're about to move into number one.
We're in fact we're about to move in the first place and move in when the whole
thing.
So my thought was this needs some investigation and there's only one man to do
it. It's me, the internet detective. So I dug into it.
I dug into his policies. I wanted you to know, listen, Hey, worst case scenario.
What happens if the megalomaniac goes and he becomes the mayor of London,
right? Well, after some long research,
I discovered his policy platform transform London, 20,
21. Sorry, Brian. I'm in your way here,
but his vision for London. So I decided we'd go through it together.
Cause I think it's very interesting what he's got going on guys.
I think you should be very worried if I were you.
The following is my transform line in 2021 plan of attack.
Now I'm going to be honest.
The policies were so vague that I did have to interpret them a little bit.
I had it because it was just a bunch of boilerplate stuff.
I didn't understand it. So I,
so I did hire some experts to try to figure out what Brian actually means. Okay?
So he says, he's going to get London back to work. How's he going to do that?
Well,
he's going to reinvigorate the economy of this great city by forcing everyone to
start a podcast and asking them to take Brian Rose's business course,
50% of all profits will be donated to the freedom platform.
So if you're the podcast he gave, this is good news for you.
You should vote for Brian health. First,
we will create the most resilient citizens in the world who are physically and
mentally robust, always prepared for times of crisis.
We will do this by asking them to drink their own urine on a daily basis.
Yeah, that's right guys. I mean, I mean, Brian Rose understands health on a,
you know, psychological level, mental level, spiritual level.
And you know, he's not going to let you go to pot. So you got to drink. You're.
Like he does every day. Uh, this is a real thing by the way you think of joking.
Okay. I'm here in London, real world headquarters waiting for Mr. Timothy sheep.
And I have a glass of a beverage. This is my own urine.
Yeah. That's a, that's a real thing that really happened.
I think he's deleted the video so far, but Hey, it's the internet detective.
We figured it out. So yeah, you got to do that.
There'll also be breakdancing every third Saturday where you're required to
HeadSpin for 30 seconds. Huh? I don't know.
That seems to play to Brian's strengths a little bit. In fact,
not only does he want you to break dance,
anyone who runs for mayor from now on has to be able to break dents. Look,
he says it in a video. Show me a mayor who can do that. He wants to challenge,
set econ to a breakdancing battle where he thinks his, uh,
he played to his strengths a little bit here.
You must be able to HeadSpin for at least 30 seconds.
If you're going to be mayor. And more importantly,
if you're gonna be a citizen of London,
either you might get locked up next on the agenda.
We've got science first again,
this is just if Brian Rose gets elected calm down, it's not going to happen.
But if he doesn't, he will make London safe.
Get by implementing rigorous science-based decisions.
When it comes to setting policies,
we believe there's been a disproportionate response to the 5g Corona scan.
Oh wow. Okay. Right.
That has caused the loss of countless lives and the let the lizard mint
takeover. Fair enough.
This can be remedied by referring all questions of science to our Supreme
science czar. Dr. David,
congratulations. David, you got yourself, um,
bit of a raise there, I think. Nice. Okay. Okay. Uh, education first,
what's this about?
We will get London back to school to ensure a bright future for our young kids.
And we will remove the culture of textbooks.
And instead every students get an hour of Joe Rogan listening every day,
followed by an hour and one minute of London, real listening guys.
This is his policies. I mean, I'm just reading off of his website, right?
I'm reading off of his website to be clear,
we will create a marketplace of ideas where censorship is no longer permitted on
our digital freedom platforms.
So long as I'm the one uploading the content and or the person talking has
donated. Okay. Uh, yeah, that I think is the,
maybe the worst part is everything will be siphoned through the London real
freedom platform.tv webpage.
So I hope you guys are used to going to that page and putting in your email.
Obviously you have to do that. So the question remains, I mean, look,
I know you're sitting there looking at the color of your own,
wondering when it's going to come to blows or swallows,
but don't worry guys. Cause I also did some digging,
not only into his policies, but also what's his likelihood of getting elected.
Is it true that he's number two in the pulse, right? Or in the bedding?
The bookies, the puppies boys. Well,
I got some bad news there, honestly. Bad news, eh, yes. It's true.
He is number two in the pulse what's going on?
Is it true that he's really got a, what does that say?
A 20% chance of winning it's complicated mystery
because when you actually look up the real polls, you know,
not just a sports bookie website, you find this,
this is the best poll I could find. Uh, Sadiq Khan of course is way ahead.
And then there's a bunch of people and then, Oh,
I can't even get it on screen right now is Arthur.
And Brian is one of the,
they actually just have this basket of others where all the mayor
candidates. Cause it's just so easy to run for. Mayor can go.
And that's where Brian is. So what's going on is Brian and last place,
is he in second place? It's a bit of a mystery.
So I looked into how bookies odds are made.
And basically this is actually what's going on. So in bookie, uh,
odds making, you know,
you obviously want to account for what is the actual likelihood of something
happening, but there's this other factor,
which is that when somebody places a big bet on something, the odds change,
because the book he doesn't want be exposed to like a huge risk.
Cause like let's say someone puts like a million dollars on the underdog. Well,
now that underdog,
even though they're not likely to win the bookie on that weird chance that they
do when they basically don't want to be bankrupt.
So they changed the odds to fit themselves better.
So let me give you guys a hypothetical to explain a, this little bookie making.
Let's just say a grifter looking for attention wants to make waves.
And he has a bunch of cash from free donations to his campaign.
Let's say instead of actually using that money for good causes,
he places a bet on himself. Theoretically,
the odds would change and he could tell his followers he's in second place while
actually not needing to get any votes at all.
He could completely in the election. And the just say it was the lizard people.
So I know that's a little bit, Hey, Hey, let's go to the conspiracy board guys.
Cause I know that's a little bit crazy, right? A little bit peppy Sylvia.
Ooh, I know that's wild,
but I'm going to just go out on a limb here and say that that's what's
happening. So, so fear,
not guys sleep well at night knowing that Brian Rose isn't in second
place. In fact it seems like he's in less place.
So the mystery is solved. Guys. The mystery of Brian Rose running for mayor.
I hope you feel like you've been kept up to date with what's going on because I
know we haven't talked about him and you might see his videos saying that he's
in first place, whatever. No, no. Somebody just placed a big bet on them.
We don't know who, uh, and his odds changed because of it.
But literally the polls are clear. No one knows who this guy is. Of course look,
the challenge is, is that when you're running for mayor,
you have to get actual people in London to vote for you.
Not like the five David followers who still haven't realized that he used them.
He used David Ike, like strictly for clout. Those guys like, yeah,
they're a fan of Brian Rose, but those guys don't usually live in London.
You know, the concentration is all over the world.
He needs to convince people specifically within the city and that's not going to
happen. All right. So that concludes trending Tuesday.
Um, let me know what you guys want to see next.
I know you guys are very invested, sorry to clickbait you with the, uh,
the dream drama guys. I honestly just, can't be bothered to talk about it today,
but let me know what you're interested in seeing,
and I'll make sure to deliver for you guys tomorrow. We got webinar Wednesdays.
Be sure to check it out when we get scammed. So you don't have to.
Thanks for watching and I'll see you.
The next.